does advertising really work US
companies spend around 170 billion
dollars on advertising yearly so they
seem to think it does successful
advertising uses a variety of tricks and
techniques to influence the consumer
they evoke positive memories and
emotions that affect our behavior over
time and prompt us to buy something at a
later date marketing needs to reach the
subconscious levels of the brain in
order for it to work people don't like
to think that they are easily influenced
humans instinctively look at something
that someone else is looking at so ads
often include a model looking right at
the main target or message it's best to
use happy faces and ads because we have
mirror neurons that prompt us to mimic
the expression of the person we are
looking at people find faces with
dilated pupils more attractive most
major advertisers increase the pupil
size of their models in Photoshop if you
position a product toward a viewers
dominant hand in an ad it heightens the
imagine product use researchers
experimenting with images of cups bowls
and sandwiches encountered the greatest
success when appealing to the right hand
side colors have powerful associations
and ads brands choose the colors of
their logos based on what they're trying
to convey red connotes action excitement
and youth green implies freshness growth
and health blue shows trust confidence
and security ads often prime the
consumer by naming a higher price
beforehand so their price is not so bad
in comparison to persuade the consumer
that their product is superior
advertisers use techniques like the
weasel claim it's vague and ambiguous
but sounds true enough that consumers
believe the claim the unfinished claim
which argues that the product is better
or has more of something but does not
finish the comparison the endorsement or
testimonial where celebrity or authority
claims to use the product when they
often don't in the 70s
Miller Lite commercials featured sports
legends and celebrities and their beer
sales increased from 7 million barrels
to 31 million
and the rhetorical question which
demands a response in such a way that
validates the products merits after the
launch of got milk sales of milk in
California rose 7% in just one year so
what do you think got brainwash
[Music]